one by one only people love jacket okay
a precarious rescue in the Mediterranean
as volunteers help refugees and migrants
off an overcrowded boats but others
haven't been so fortunate according to
Human Rights Watch at least 1200 people
died trying to reach Europe between
January and September this year
and on Sunday the head of the Roman
Catholic Church unexpectedly referred to
the ongoing tragedy
the exclusion of migrants is scandalous
indeed it's criminal and see it makes
them die in front of us and so today the
Mediterranean is the world's largest
cemetery the exclusion of migrants is
disgusting it is sinful
some will see his comments as a warning
to Giorgio Maloney who's expected to
become Italy's Prime Minister later this
month her brothers of Italy party came
first in September's election part of a
right-wing Coalition that wants to speed
up repatriations and introduce tougher
Asylum rules
this board will not change
Vision to have some kind of standing
within you know the institution and and
political landscape
before the election Georgia Maloney
called for a naval blockade of North
Africa
it's not clear why Europe cannot help
Italy defend the eu's external borders
overlooking the Mediterranean by
negotiating with the Libyan government
one of her Coalition Partners the Lego
party is headed by Mateo salvini Italy's
Hardline former interior Minister last
year he went on trial for abduction and
dereliction of Duty over his refusal to
let a charity boat bring rescued
migrants to the island of lampedusa
while he'd like his old job back
political sources say Maloney's
resisting hoping to get EU backing for
her plans to stop people leaving North
Africa Nadine barber Al Jazeera